wonder hmm is there something special  about today  well i know the apron is a bit much dear  but i am doing my best to blend in  no no they're on the calendar someone's  drawn a little hard  right above today's day oh yes the heart  well don't tell me you have forgotten  this forgotten a wonder i'm incapable of  forgetfulness i remember everything  that's not an exaggeration in fact  i'm incapable of exaggeration well then  tell me what's so important about  today's date  [Music]  what was the question again oh god  haven't you forgotten yourself hey  heavens no i've been so looking forward  to it as have i  today we are celebrating you bet we are  it's the first time we  have ever celebrated this occasion  before it's a  special day perhaps an evening great  significance to us  naturally obviously exactly hold on us